die köpfe unten ja ich will mein name
ist luca meine damen und herren im juli
sitzt hinter der kamera
vor zwei wochen haben wir bereits ein
video hochgeladen in dem ich typische
frauen produkt sag ich mal natürlich
können die produkte auch männer benutzen
allerdings habe ich so typische frauen
produkte erraten die jule mir hier vor
die kamera gegeben hat und jule hat mal
wieder zwölf oder dreizehn produkt
rausgesucht sie mir jetzt geben wird und
ich denke dass ich was sage was ich
denke was das ist
das ist mein erstes produkt für dich das
ist etwas das wir abgeklebt
ich dachte erst das wäre design aspekt
das kannst du mit etwas verwechselt
ok ich weiß was du denkst was ich denke
was das sein könnte
ich glaube du denkst dass ich denke dass
das die reine black märz sein könnte
nein kann sie sagen doch aufwachen
sollen die mal angucken ich würde auf
den ersten blick denken dass das hier
eine black messe ist dass es so schwarz
you better world improve und porta pro
ja vielleicht noch nicht also wir können
das ganze hier aufdrehen und keine
schokolade ist es so eine mattierende
creme
es ist ja aber ich habe jetzt wird ihr
und sein soll was denkst du denn
entsprechend der farbe gab es eine
getönte tagescreme das heißt es ist kein
make up sondern so eine getönte creme
die eben einfach ein bisschen frischer
aussehen das sehen auch die improve
roger kusch dass man eben auch beim
sport ein bisschen schöner aussehen kann
ein anderes produkt stimmt ganz so auch
aufmachen
es ist ein stift long wait den usa sechs
stunden mit dem franzosen also man sieht
hier oben die farbe was das ganze sein
könnte wird wissen wir das ist auf jeden
fall ist es einen stift und wenn wir den
augen dafür die mine mit dem kannst du
nicht so gut meint also der stift ich
muss auf jeden fall noch angespitzt
werden
ich glaube aber wenn ich mir so die
farbe anschaue das ist ein stift ist für
die lippen ja dass man kenne ich diese
videos auf insider berichtet so was halt
immer vorgeschlagen da war hier so rum
und die lippen und dann auch noch so
drauf auch ja es ist halt so die lippen
zu einem run homerun dann gefüllt wenn
das mit lippenstift dann genau sagte das
glaube ich relativ einfach ich hoffe es
ist eine kleine mini nasa mondrakete die
man doch ganz klar das ist ein punkt den
steckt man sich und die nutze ich auch
immer die besten sind die allerbesten
weg von gut oder schlecht sein darauf an
wie ja das ist ein tampon auf jeden fall
kollegen
bei der wundertüte jetzt habe ich etwas
da wusste ich dass bekommen haben auch
erst nicht was zu ist deswegen habe ich
das nicht zubekommen aus dass man
irgendwie geschenkt bekommen ist es
vielleicht einen soft focus highlighter
die sache ist allerdings dass wir das
halt wirklich nicht als beim politik war
seine soft focus highlighter wie sie
schreiben sich irgendwas deutsches drauf
von wegen ja das ist der firmen die
augen heller zu machen das sieht so aus
wie diese teile die man im zoo
zigarettenanzünder was dann schickt
seine zigarette da so rein gab es nicht
in autos früher und tabak lobby soft
focus highlight wieder so anschauen also
man kann das hier so drehen oder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für die augen
nein nicht für die wangenknochen ja das
ist unter den augen paar den banken hier
darum ja und auf denn da kann man es
auch benutzen dafür dass licht hin fällt
natürlich reisen macht man das sind
damit noch mehr reflektiert was ist wenn
das licht von unten kommt ja da hast
halt nicht gehört habe ich was der
winter verraten wir hier das für dich
ich weiß für das ist wenn ich einfach
mal so einen dummen nachdenken vier
teile ich glaube da könntest du deine
finger reinstecken und das dann habt ihr
eine oberfläche legen damit die
lackieren kannst es ist eigentlich
wichtig oder ist ein schlag
das ist nummer davon würde auch als
verspielt
die füße was ihre grenzen
lackiert bei wenn die dann trocknen
lässt die cd sind wir soweit bayern doch
noch die ganz so einfach die finger so
ist es von angenehmen musste die finger
gar nicht mehr so halten das hier ist
für dich aber darf nicht behalten nein
ja das mega
das finde ich als trainer bei frauen
sachen kümmern da hast du direkt sohn
james bond kit damit drin also dass hier
sieht ja so ein bisschen stammt ich
jetzt meinen finger glaube das ist halt
sehr gutes für unterwegs war dann kann
es auch klappen hat direkten spiegel
kannst das herausnehmen noch einmal
aufklappen das in den schwarm rändern
diese bitte guck dir nicht die rückseite
an wo ich nicht akut halt macht einfach
auch nicht dann gucken wir können nicht
mal aufträge und daran riechen dann rein
stecken und dann drehst du
wie einmal und dann ist der nagellack ab
und normalerweise muss ja den
nagellackentferner auf dem ipad machen
und sagen du schreiben und das alles an
direkt auf produkte hier finde ich sie
aus unserer süßigkeit also das hier ist
auf ersten blick etwas was ich noch nie
drei darf ich dich hier steht allerdings
auch nichts drauf was mir micro rogan
der concealer was hat das jetzt auch
steht für dich da ist ziemlich alt in
der tiefsee auch in den kram ich habe
ich immer sage ich das war ich in meiner
kindheit kranich dresden fahren dann
wird das da es für eingepreist alter
arzt direkt auf was für ideen
mittlerweile die firmen kommt ist
unfassbar
natürlich weit weg
ich bin erklärt sind zum hat für vergabe
waren beispiel in der felswand opel
nannte es ist eigentlich ein nippel beim
für ja ich weiß ja nicht dafür aber ich
habe bei so einer anderen bären gesehen
dass du das mal für ihre lippen benutzt
ein mittel beim das sieht es zum
beispiel ihre lippen benutzt und das ist
echt gut weil das aus dieser liga also
es ist eigentlich ein mittel bleiben
gewesen allerdings nutzt man den auch
manchmal für die lippen interessant
wimpern macht man am schluss davon
abhängt hat nicht gefehlt aber versagen
also dass hier kann man da kann man die
wimpern mit voluminöser machen ja dann
bietet die damit so ein bisschen mehr da
irgendwie länger aus und sagen ja die
heißt es wenn du überlegst man quetscht
etwas ein
wimpern quetschen 1
wie heißt du sonst mit dir was
zusammendrückt quetschen ein
wimpernzange der häufig den komplett ab
das hier ist das vorletzte produkt da
darfst du nicht unten drauf gucken
lassen könnte weil das habe ich nicht
abgeklebt aber nun lukas
nein ich glaube es nicht so kleine
bällchen die pac man auf diesen schwamm
hier drauf und dann kann man das so
ähnlich auch benutzen wie so ein
highlight
es ist auch ein highlight aber durch
weil das glänzt ein bisschen entrückt
den schwank warst du da drauf und dann
nutzt den schwarm und okay das ist jetzt
das selbst noch nie benutzt wird neu
kauft euch dieses video das war nicht
für muttermilch oder die sonne glocke
die man so läuten so das man
[Musik]
bis 23 eine menstruation passe heißt
wenn man seine freiheit steckt ja da hat
mir das okay ich hab ich glaube ich weiß
dass amberg stelle würde ich das heute
wieder ins allerdings auch beende ich
meine liebe freundin wenn es euch
gefallen hat dass ich mal wieder auf
einige typische frauen produkte
natürlich können männer diese produkte
auch benutzen aber es sind halt nur
typische frauen produkte in der
frauenabteilung von dm wenn manchmal
erraten beziehung meine reaktion auf
diese produkte gefallen hat dann das
gerne einen daumen hoch bei diesem video
da sollen wurde und ich werde ja noch
einen dritten teil drehen schreibt zum
scannen und die kommentare und jetzt
kommt das auto
[Musik]